der krieg ist zurück in europa die armee
des russischen präsidenten fällt in der
ukraine ein er will grenzen verschieben
ist bereit bis zum äußersten zu gehen
wäre das zu verhindern gewesen durch
eine härtere politik des westens
deutschlands der ukrainische botschafter
in berlin sieht sein land als opfer
einer episch und politik
die ukraine fühlen sich als ein
opferlamm
und als quasi eine folge von von von
dieser beschwichtigungspolitik
deutschlands in den letzten jahren auch
in den letzten monaten vielleicht um das
macht meine landsleute das macht auch
nicht persönlich wütend dialog hieß
bislang der deutsche ansatz man sah sich
in der vermittlerrolle wandel durch
handel
ein anderer glaubenssatz putin ein
partner kein aggressor daran änderten
auch seine luftangriffe auf georgien
nichts auch nicht die annexion der krim
hinweise wurden überhört ein russland
das nicht so sein wollte wie wir schwer
vorstellbar ich glaube schon ist die
deutsche politik die veränderung in der
welt nicht ganz mitbekommen hat in den
letzten jahren sogar jahrzehnten und
häufig in deutschland der fall ist dass
man die politik in die internationale
politik sender ihr betrachtet
vermittlungsversuche bis zum bitteren
ende putin verhöhnt alle besucher am
langen tisch mit dieser woche ist klar
die deutsche russland politik ist
gescheitert putin hat die
verhandlungsbereitschaft von uns
ausgenutzt und hat gesehen dass dahinter
weder die absicht ist dies militärisch
zu unterfüttern noch die bereitschaft
diplomatie und härte eindeutig zu zeigen
die deutsche außenpolitik am
scheidepunkt ratlos eine härtere gangart
bislang hat man sie vermieden wollte
ungern in unpopuläre dinge wie militär
investieren und abschreckung wollte
niemanden verprellen nun muss man sich
neu aufstellen
das heißt nicht dass man werte vergessen
soll aber es wird wesentlich mehr darauf
ankommen auch mit härte die westlichen
die demokratischen interessen zu
verteidigen
ich glaube das müssen wir erst wieder
neu lernen denn das haben wir verlernt
einmal aus guten gründen weil
deutschland mal in seiner geschichte
vieles falsch gemacht hat aber ein
bisschen auch weil es halt bequem war
und diese zeit ist zu ende eine neue
glaubwürdige außenpolitik klar scheint
verteidigungsfähigkeit gehört dazu
ministerin lamprecht empfängt 350
zusätzliche soldaten in litauen es gilt
die ostflanke zu stärken wir stehen hier
wachsam und wehrhaft
ganz so ist es nicht die bundeswehr muss
sich strecken die aktuellen wünsche der
nato zu erfüllen drei zusätzliche
eurofighter nach rumänien eine korvette
eine kompanie in die slowakei noch immer
hat man die truppe nicht von
auslandseinsätzen umgestellt auf bündnis
und landesverteidigung das tut nun aber
nur wenn es um den sozusagen luftabwehr
gürtel geht wenn es aber gleichzeitig um
bodentruppen geht um unsere eurofighter
um unsere schiffe dann wissen wir genau
schauen wo haben wir was verfügbar es
ist nicht mehr alles selbstverständlich
da und diese mangelverwaltung die macht
uns natürlich nahezu wahnsinnig
tagtäglich heute verspricht kanzler
scholz der bundeswehr 100 milliarden
euro extra doch es wird dauern bis die
in der truppe ihre wirkung zeigen und
die mentalität in der außenpolitik muss
sich ändern wenn wir das nicht
verknüpfen mit einer realpolitischen
sicht auf die internationalen
beziehungen damit das alles nichts
bringen also jetzt mehr geld der
bundeswehr zu geben wird nichts bringen
wenn man sozusagen mentalitätsmäßig
nicht realisiert dass diese streitkräfte
ein instrument deutscher außenpolitik
sind mit deren einsatz waren auch drohen
kann der präsident von litauen ist nach
berlin gekommen für ein gespräch mit dem
kanzler stippvisite bei demonstranten
vor der russischen botschaft
er befürchte putin wird auch nach
anderen osteuropäischen ländern greifen
er will unterstützung und beobachtet
eine änderung im deutschen denken
einige augen wurden geöffnet
noch vor zwei drei monaten war es
manchmal recht kompliziert über russland
ebenso viele vorbehalte und tradition
doch jetzt beginnt jeder zu verstehen
was passiert
waffenlieferungen sind nun möglich genau
wie russlands ausschluss aus dem
internationalen zahlungssystemen eine
zeitenwende in der deutschen
außenpolitik deutet sich an putins
brutalität ließ keine andere wahl